[Music]
[Applause]
still trying to get some answers what's
going on with the Boston Celtics all I
know is their head coach has been
suspended for a season Ma udoka has been
suspended for a season and it's one of
those that you say what do we not know
in this situation and if it's a year
why do you even bring him back after a
year if it if something happened that
you sit him down for a year why are you
going to bring him back after a year yes
and if it's not so bad that you have to
fire him that you're willing to bring
them back then why is he even really
suspended at all just then find him or
something and let them coach I don't
really understand that let's bring in
Chris Mannix all right which question do
you want to answer first
there's a lot of them there Dan and
understandably there's a lot we still
don't know
um
one of them the decision to suspend him
for one year I think is the most
interesting one as is the language the
Celtics used in announcing this
suspension uh they made it clear in that
three sentence press release that this
was as of now not a situation where it's
a guarantee that email udoka is going to
come back which
tells me in in pretty blank terms that
the intention is not to bring imeiodoka
back now after that
you know you get into maybe some of the
the gray area there about does a guy get
fired and get fired for cause if he
quits you know what are we what about
the money I think that's frankly an area
that we're in with the Celtics and IMEI
udoku but it was an interesting decision
an interesting choice of language to use
in announcing the suspension Robert
Sarver was being suspended for a year
and fined 10 million dollars if I
include udoka's salary
it's very similar to the punishment that
an owner got
yeah it is it is a very punitive
punishment for email delka which which
really makes you wonder exactly what was
going on behind the scenes that the
Celtics look they don't want to to push
out ineudoka they didn't want to push
him out I mean this is a championship
team you know going that goes into the
season as one of the odds on favorites
to win the title at ime udoka is
instrumental in all that was
instrumental in what they did last year
and was going to be counted on to do the
same things this year they're just
at this moment Dan there's too many
variables that are unaccounted for I I
believe in from what I've been told in
coming to the decision on the suspension
one of the things the Celtics took into
consideration was the fact that this
woman was a subordinate to email doka I
was told one of the things that was
taken into consideration was the fact
that
um according to people in the know this
was a married woman that he was involved
with
um
it uh it there are still some things
that are unclear specifically how the
relationship started how it ended and
what exactly triggered the Celtics to
investigate in the manner that they did
and quickly come to this conclusion and
this is a team punishment the league has
nothing to do with this
the league has nothing to do with this
this is strictly something the Celtics
are are running
okay
if you get the feeling that he's not
coming back after this then what did the
Celtics do at the head coaching position
well
the interim head coach and look Joe
Missoula is a
very well respected young guy 34 years
old his head coaching experience
effectively amounts to two seasons in
division two but he's been in the NBA
for three years he interviewed and was
one of the finalists for the Utah Jazz
head coaching job last summer a job that
ironically went to udoka's top assistant
will hardy
um a couple of months ago so there is a
sense that Joe Missoula is a coach in
waiting and perhaps that's what Brad
Stevens is looking for in making this
decision
um he could have promoted more
experienced guys he could have said
Damon Stoudemire former player then a
head coach in college
um yeah it has been and then be around
the NBA for much longer Ben Sullivan he
was the coach of the Celtics summer
league team he's a front of the bench
guy as well one of the things that you
know people have talked to me about is
perhaps Brad Stevens is not just looking
for a stop gap for this year but for a
head coach with a foreseeable future
because frankly Dan if Brad Stevens was
just looking for a stop Gap the choice
should have been him yeah uh you know
Brad Stevens is only a year removed from
concluding an eight-year run as Celtics
coach a successful run as Celtics coach
he's still considered one of the best
basketball Minds in the NBA he knows the
Personnel he knows what it takes to
coach them you know that was my initial
thought that Brad Stevens would kind of
take one for the team and come back down
and hold dual roles for at least one
season but in promoting Joe Missoula at
least on an interim basis
um it's it's signals to me that perhaps
they're looking for not just a coach for
this season but a coach for years to
come
and I know you tweeted out that maybe
Frank Vogel could join the coaching
staff
yeah Frank Vogel has a long-standing
relationship with Brad Stevens that
dates back to Brad's days in college and
when Frank was coaching uh the Indiana
Pacers uh during his time away from the
game between jobs at Orlando and La he
visited the Celtics you know spent some
time around Brad Stevens I know they've
got a close relationship if you look at
that Celtics bench the one thing it's
lacking is an established former head
coach there isn't one there right now
Frank Vogel
unemployed at the moment not obviously
not a candidate for any job you know at
the moment
um I I would think he will be someone
that gets some consideration to join
that coaching staff
I just looked at the odds the current
odds on DraftKings
the Celtics are still currently listed
as the favorite to win the NBA title
they have the talent
um
but I I am a believer Dan that the head
coach matters and look email udoka
proved that last year didn't he I mean
this team was a disaster for two months
it took email yodoka two months to break
players of bad individual habits and to
implement a brand new Switch heavy
defense that turned them into the best
defensive team in the NBA he also was
one of the earliest and strongest
advocates for Marcus Smart's ability to
play point guard so
he he played a key role in all this and
as smart as Joe Missoula is and I've
I've been around Boston a lot I know I
know him I I believe he's a very smart
guy it's an incredibly difficult ass or
tough ask
place this 34 year old days before the
start of training camp right onto a team
expected to win a championship it's just
look yeah Brad Stevens in the Celtics
front office looked they've they've
earned a bit of a benefit of Doubt look
I thought it was insane to promote Brad
Stevens to Danny ainge's job that worked
out email yodoka while I liked him a lot
to be the head coach of the team a year
ago he was not some home run candidate
that was an obvious coach that worked
out maybe they see something and Joe
Missoula that makes makes them believe
he's ready for that job but it is a a
tall task for a young coach to step into
this situation and succeed
thank you Chris I know you got a busy
morning thanks for joining us
that's Chris Mannix Sports illustrator
senior NBA writer